(rock music)
- What's up, guys?
Today is going to be a super fun video.
I've been seeing a lot of people do sensory
deprivation tanks, which is basically
just a soundproof, lightproof tank with water
in it that you can float on, so it's basically
just like meditation, but the only problem
is, they're pretty expensive, and they're always
booked up, so I thought, why not make my own?
So I'm going to my friend Marlin's place
right now, he's a YouTuber, he does those crazy
gummy videos and other DIY stuff,
so I really think he can help.
Yo, what up?
Have you heard of a sensory deprivation tank?
- No, what is that?
- It's like the Dead Sea, basically.
- Oh, you float!
Well, let's make it.
- You think we can make it here?
^- I think we can do it.
- [Eric] Yeah, you know what that is?
- Yeah!
^- [Marlin] Wait, they did it in Stranger Things?
^(eerie music)
^- What, are you guys, like, making
^a tank or what?
- [Eric] Yeah, you want to help us?
- Yeah!
- [Eric] Alright, salt, we need salt.
- Salt, okay, great.
I've got salt right here, bang, bang, salt!
- Yes, we need a pool.
- I've got a pool, let's go.
- You've got a pool?
- I've got a pool, it's right there.
It's a little dirty, though, but
you don't think we need to clean that?
- I mean, it's water.
- It's water.
- If this works, you guys are gonna
^go to, like, another dimension or something.
- I'm down, let's do it!
Alright, since Marlin's a professional
YouTuber, we're going to do the YouTube
quick-change into my shorts, are you ready?
- Alright, here we go.
- Okay, wait, we've got to do that again.
- Let's try that again.
- It always messes up sometimes.
We haven't perfected it yet.
- Alright, here we go.
- This isn't working.
- This is not working.
- Should I just change?
I'll just change, let's change.
Quick, faster, time's running out.
- We'll speed this up, right?
(loud groaning)
- Fast-forward it!
(electronic music)
- Oh, my socks.
Alright, sensory deprivation tank time!
(cheering)
I feel really alone, you guys sure
you don't want to join me?
- Yeah, I'm good for right now, but um--
- Yeah, I'm good, too.
- Yeah.
- Alright, oh my god, it is so cold!
Now, I'm going to lay down, and then you guys
will salt me, and then I'm going to float up.
(hip hop music)
Why are you salting me?
- You said salt you!
- No, salt the water!
- [Eric Voiceover] After salting the water for 30 minutes,
it was time to test it out.
(drum roll imitation)
Yeah, I'm not floating, it's not working,
I'm done, I give up.
- That tastes, that's not salty enough at all.
- What just happened?
- If you watched Stranger Things, you would know
you need 1500 pounds of salt to do this!
- Are you sure it worked in the show?
- Yes, Eleven went to another dimension!
- Alright, then we're getting 1500 pounds
of salt!
So I'm going to call Costco, see how much
1500 pounds of Epsom salt costs.
- They may not even have it, though.
- What, salt?
- Yeah, just call them.
- Wait, how much?
My budget for this video is $300.
I guess the video is over here
because I can't spend $2000--
- Wait, wait, wait, I've got a magician friend.
He's made, like, Ferraris appear, so like,
I don't get why he can't just make
1500 pounds of salt appear.
- So your magician friend could
make all of our salt appear right now?
- Yes, he was on Ellen, so...
- The magician's name is Daniel Fernandez, and he
really was on Ellen, so there's still hope.
- Alright, yeah, so my friend's already here.
He just texted me.
- Oh, awesome.
(yells loudly)
So today, I'm going to float on water.
I need your help.
- Ooh, I mean, I could just make you
walk on water.
(cheers and laughs loudly)
- [Eric Voiceover] I couldn't believe that I had
just walked on water, but I was even more excited
that I just got an awesome thumbnail and title.
We still needed Daniel to make the salt appear.
- One, two, breathe in.
(breathes loudly)
- Whoa, oh my god!
- I don't like that!
- [Eric Voiceover] He kept doing tricks
that had nothing to do with salt,
but they were really cool, so I'm
not complaining.
(screaming)
I reminded Daniel for the third time
that we need him to make salt appear,
so he told us he would turn our cash into salt.
- Close your eyes, and I want you to concentrate.
- [Group] Ten, nine, eight, seven--
- [Eric] He definitely ran away.
- Did he run away?
- Wait, what?
- [Eric] (bleep) You closed your eyes,
you lost it!
- He told me to!
- Alright, so the magician stole all our money,
but it's okay because he did some cool tricks.
I think we should do some math, like,
we have three brains right here, we'll figure
out exactly how much salt we need
and what we need to float.
Cut to the dope montage.
(hip hop music)
What?
These guys didn't do anything, but I
actually figured it out, here's what
we've got to do, you guys ready?
The pool holds a thousand liters,
and I googled the Dead Sea, which is what
we're trying to replicate, and the Dead Sea
has 1.24 kilograms of salt per liter.
So if we have a thousand liters in the pool,
we need 250 kilograms, about 250 kilograms
to make the pool like the Dead Sea.
Now, that's still expensive because that's 550 pounds
when you convert it, but if we do
half the pool and we only fill the pool
to 500 liters, we need 275 pounds of salt.
Does this make sense, are you guys following?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Totally, totally.
- [Eric Voiceover] We went to the store, well,
rolled to the store, grabbed the salt, a lot
of it, actually, and rolled out in style.
We then had to carry all the bags
up to the roof, which was really hard
because they were each 40 pounds.
I guess that's not that much, but it
was really heavy.
We also had to carry pots of boiling water
to the roof because I realized I needed
warm water for the salt to dissolve.
We poured the water into the pool
and started filling it with salt.
It felt like we were in a scene from
an epic Italian mobster movie.
(Italian folk music)
After four hours of mixing and waiting,
it was time to test it out.
- Eric, Eric--
- My butt's floating.
- That's awesome!
- I'm not kidding.
- (laughs) The way he looked at me right there.
- What, are you actually floating?
- Oh my god, bro!
- Are you floating?
- Yeah, he's floating!
- I'm floating!
- He's floating!
- [Eric Voiceover] I couldn't believe
that it worked, it was amazing.
I was so relaxed, I felt like I was flying.
My mind went blank, I was totally
free, so free that I peed a little.
The video wasn't over yet, though.
To make it a real sensory deprivation
tank, I needed to make it soundproof
and lightproof, so I covered myself
with a blanket.
And then I went to another dimension!
Guys, I disappeared, I'm doing this voiceover
from the Upside Down right now!
I'm chilling with Eleven, Eleven, say hi.
- [Eleven Voiceover] Hey guys, hey everyone.
- [Eric Voiceover] That's right, I'm hanging
out with the Eleven right now in
the Upside Down because of a DIY
sensory deprivation tank that I made.
It was totally worth it, you guys
should totally do it, I had a blast, thanks
to Marlin and Austin.
Make sure to check their links down below.
I'll see you guys in the next video.
Alright, how do I get back?
Eleven, where'd you go, guys?
Oh, no.
(violin and accordion music)